[Musique]
bienvenue à willisau amber là vous
nettoyer toute la nuit willy seconde
demande et je paie les réparations de
votre voiture
voilà officiellement dans l'ic allez
viens restons pas dans les parages je
supporte pas d'entendre un homme crier
cette ville a une telle histoire
je sais les conneries qui vous en
raconter églises ont menti
ils vous ont offert en sacrifice
[Musique]
vous avez entendu tout ce que je viens
de vous raconter
il va mourir s'il reste ici mais il ne
m'écoute pas
[Musique]
les robots sont sortis
personne ne sera à l'abri
mais ta paire de couilles avec 4
android
c'est pas lui qui est tombé dans leur
sillage
qui son pied ici avec lui
eh bien
de faire la paire j'aime les hommes qui
parlent peu